long ago in algebra class we learned to
factor things like x squared minus y
squared we saw that this is a difference
of squares that you could factor this as
x plus y
times x minus y and just a little bit of
refresher you can multiply these two
together and verify that you get x
squared minus y squared in fact let's
just do that for fun x times x is
x squared x times negative y is negative
xy
y times x is positive x y and then y
times negative y is minus y squared
these two middle terms cancel out and
you're left with x squared minus y
squared
what i want to tackle in this video
is something that we didn't know how to
factor before and that's the sum of the
squares
so if we were to factor x let me just in
a brighter
and a brighter color if we wanted to try
to factor x squared plus y squared
before we knew about imaginary numbers
complex numbers we didn't know how to
factor this but now that we do what i
want to try to do and i encourage you
actually to pause the video and try to
do it before me is to try to express
this as a difference of squares using
the imaginary unit i
so let's try to do this so
the first we want to write as a
difference of squares so x squared we
can just keep as x squared but now i
want to write this part i want to write
the second part right over here
as
subtracting a square so i want to
subtract a square so we could write this
part as subtracting
negative
y squared obviously you subtract a
negative that's the same thing as adding
now how does this help us well this is
the same thing as subtracting negative 1
times y squared
now what is if we wanted to write this
whole thing as a square if we wanted to
rewrite if we wanted to write this whole
thing as a square how would we do it
well we have y squared and what's
negative 1 the square of well we know by
definition
negative 1 by definition negative 1 is
equal to i squared or that i is equal to
or i squared is equal to negative 1. so
let's rewrite it that way so this is
going to be equal to x squared
minus
instead of negative 1 i'll write that as
i squared
minus i squared
y squared all i replaced all i did is i
replaced this negative 1 with an i
squared and now this is interesting and
i think you see where this is going but
i'll just make it very explicit this is
now x squared
minus
x squared
i
y
squared
and just like that using i i've been
able to write this sum of squares as a
difference of squares and now we can
factor it just the exact same way that
we factored this original expression
this thing is going to be equal to so
it's going to be equal to x
x
plus
this thing
i y x plus
i y
times
x
minus i y
x minus
i
y
and we can verify that if you multiply
these two expressions together you're
going to get x squared plus y squared
let's do that
let's do that x times x is x squared
x times negative i y is negative i
x y
and then
i y times x is positive i
x y
and then finally
finally let me do this in a color i'm
not using yet finally i y times negative
iy
is equal to
negative i squared y squared
now these middle two terms cancel out
i squared is negative one and so we have
x squared minus negative one y squared
so this is subtracting a negative the
same thing as adding a positive and so
this simplifies to
x squared
plus
x squared plus y squared so hopefully
this now gives you an appreciation of
using
using the complex the the imaginary unit
i how you can actually factor this
expression into essentially the product
of two complex numbers